on va passer évidemment à la loi
immigration coup de théâtre hier à
l'Assemblée nationale les députés ont
rejeté le texte avant même le début de
son examen Gérald haranin concède un
échec Jonathan Dupri pour 270 contre
265 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté dans
une ambiance électrique le texte
immigration est rejeté à 5 voix près par
l'Assemblée nationale avant même d'avoir
pu être examiné hier dans l'hémicycle du
Palais Bourbon le vote de la motion de
rejet a pris des allures de des routes
pour le ministre de l'Intérieur chargé
depuis des mois de trouver une majorité
pour porter sa réforme vous étiez à
l'Élysée dans le bureau du président de
la République vous l'avez présenté votre
démission oui l'a-t-il accepté ou refusé
non le président de la République l' l'a
refusé je constate que l'alliance des
contraire du RN DLR de l'anupes qui
pense absolument différemment certains
veulent beaucoup plus d'immigration
d'autres plus du tout certains veulent
sortir de l'Europe d'autres veent plus
d'Europe et Ben se sont mis d'accord
pour faire tomber pour des raisons de
politique aïie le texte du Gouvernement
plutôt dans la journée les oppositions
ont fait une alliance de circonstances
pour faire tomber le texte
gouvernemental le RN tout d'abord qui
ménageait le suspense sur ses intentions
a finalement rallé la motion issue de la
gauche désaveux qui vient de s'exprimer
ce soir est un désaveux extrêmement
puissant un désaveux aussi du en même
temps qui est une véritable escroquerie
politique et qui se révèle plus
surprenant encore 40 des 62 députés du
groupe voter la motion de rejet pour
Eric cotti le gouvernement paye comptant
le détricotage du texte sénatorial voté
en première lecture nous l'avons en
toute cohérence aujourd'hui adopté non
pas pour interrompre les débats sur un
sujet essentiel mais pour que les débats
se poursuivent sur une base beaucoup
plus crédible que celle qui avait été
emprunté par la majorité en détricotant
totalement le texte du sénatoire pour la
gauche également qui fait pression pour
obtenir le retrait P et simple du texte
nous demandons maintenant à ce
gouvernement de retirer cette loi je
crois que tout le monde doit comprendre
que la macronie rentre maintenant dans
une crise de pouvoir qui est extrêmement
profonde et que ce qui est en train de
se passé c'est la question de savoir
quelle légitimité reste à ce
gouvernement la balle est désormais dans
le camp du gouvernement hier soir une
réunion de crise s tenu à matigon pour
déterminer les suites à apporter à ce
texte de son côté l'Élysée dit attendre
du ouement des propositions pour lever
les blocages et aboutir à un texte
efficace jérôe cordelier ça a été une
surprise ce rejet du texte avant même le
début de oui c'était une surprise
effectivement voilà c'est surtout une
bêtise par C c'est une bêtise à la fois
de la part du pouvoir c'est une bêtise
de la part de ceux qui ont voté la
motion de rejet parce que il il rejette
dans le dans le débat public enfin un
spectacle absolument désolant de de la
vie politique c'est une enfin c'est une
bêtise de la part de tout le monde hein
c'est-à-dire que l'Assemblée nationale
apparaît encore comme un hémicycle qui
n'est pas tenu avec enfin les les les
jeux du cirque et le le pouvoir est
vraiment sinon dans une crise politique
en tout cas dans une crise d'autorité on
voit bien que Emmanuel Macron a de a de
plus en plus de mal à à avoir prise sur
le sur sur les événements on va venir
sur après et Gérard armanin c'est vrai a
beaucoup euh il a fait énormément de de
de de rendez-vous pour essayer de de de
de enfin il a fait la politique à
l'ancienne he en multipliant les
déjeunés les petits-déjeunés avec tous
les parlementaires ça n'a pas suffi pour
lui c'est un échec il l'a reconnaît
lui-même je je trouve que Gérard darin
gère bien pour le coup son échec
c'est-à-dire on voit bien le le le le le
vieux briscard de la politique déjà à la
manœuvre qui d'emblé reconnaît son échec
euh présente sa démission au président
de la République qui a refusé
voilà mais le spectacle qui est donné je
trouve de de la de la démocratie
parlementaire et de la démocratie
publique est assez consternant en fait
bien c'est une bêtise alors ça c'est
vrai que Gérald Darmanin a très bien
géré je trouve son échec ce qui
l'enterre l'enterre un peu vite je
trouve qu'il a très bien réagi et même
si c'est un échec cuisant effectivement
pour pour ce gouvernement je je ne crois
pas que ce soit une bêtise en revanche
je ne pense pas que ce soit une une
victoire pour qui que ce soit je pense
que tout le monde a perdu hier on sait
pas très bien et d'ailleurs ce qui ce
qui gagne aujourd'hui c'est
l'incertitude on sait pas par où va
repasser le texte si ça va être en CMP
encore à cette heure-ci si ça repasse en
lecture au Sénat ce qu'il adviendra de
ce texte à l'Assemblée nationale s'il
sera plus durci et si le gouvernement
validera finalement ce texte et si on va
parler de l'avenir du texte mais vous
vous dites tout le monde a perdu ça veut
dire que les les ouras de la gauche rés
plis c'est sûr qu'on peut pas on va pas
bouder le plaisir de voir le
gouvernement enfin mis en échec et euh
mis à la lumière du jour le fait que il
n'y a pas de majorité pour gouverner
dans ce pays donc ce que je disais tout
à l'heure quand je disais qu'on est dans
une période d'incertitude c'est à quel
moment il y aura une dissolution parce
qu'à un moment donné il faut faut
arrêter de se raconter des histoires si
on veut avancer si le quinquena veut
avancer il va bien falloir dégager des
majorités d'idées dans ce Parlement donc
ça veut dire un retour aux jurnnes et
c'est l'échec personnel euh pour vous de
Gérald ranin on va parler de la suite
après mais sur vraiment ce qui s'est
passé hier à l'Assemblée est-ce que
c'est un échec personnel de jardin ou
c'est plus global que ça est-ce qu' a
est-ce qu'il a la responsabilité unique
de ce qui s'est passé hier unique non on
voit bien que si vous voulez on voit
bien que le le le le le le pouvoir
depuis le début de ce quinquena mais à
la fin du quinquena précédent euh pé
enfin pardon cette expression mais
un peu dans la semoule quoi
c'est-à-dire que il y a il y a pas de
prix sur les événements euh le problème
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de cette majorité
qui n'arrive euh pas pas pas à trouver
euh on parlait de majorité vous vous
avez parlé de majorité desidé plus
plutôt de de de de gouvernement par
coalition ça ne marche pas donc on voit
bien que là le le et même Carl Liv ce
matin sur France Info disait que bon ben
il faut aller à à la dissolution quoi
donc on voit bien que là il y a on est
dans un dans une impasse dans un blocage
institutionnel désormais on était déjà
dans un blocage politique maintenant on
est dans un blocage institutionnel donc
comment s'en sortir et puis surtout avec
des des des des Français qui s'éloignent
de plus en plus
de de de de la politique et du jeu
démocratique vous vous réjouissez d'une
situation comme ça c'est ce que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure moi non
c'est-à-dire je trouve que c'est
vraiment le le spectacle qui est donné
pour une réforme en plus qui est voulu
par 8 Français sur 10 c'est c'est
concernant c'est navrant je ne me
réjouis pas de la situation je me
réjouis de l'échec à la fois personnel
de géralanin de cette majorité qui joue
quand même dansun certain cyisme et
d'une certaine arrogance depuis quand
même quelques temps que ce soit on dit
que c'est le match retour sur la réforme
des retraite je n'y crois pas du tout ça
na absolument ent rien à voir mais en
revanche c'est pour ça que je dis que il
y a allez on peut on peut se féliciter
quand même que ce gouvernement é mis en
échec compte tenu de l' rogance compte
tenu du cynisme qu'il y a eu notamment
sur ce texte il faut rappeler quand même
que Gérald harmanin a usé de tous ses
stratagèmes pour mettre la pression sur
le député mettre la pression sur les
parlementaires sur les sur les préfets
qui eux-mêmes envoyaient les listes des
expulsables au députés avec un certain
nombre de qui qui ont été c'était assez
ignob comme commeous
dis entendu monsieur canner en parler
tout à l'heure et et je trouve que
l'argument le plus vraiment qui moi qui
je trouve vraiment détestable c'est
d'avoir accusé les députés qui ne
voteraient pas ce texte d'être les
complices des futurs actes terroristes
quiuraient dans le pays je trouve je
trouve l'argument vraiment abject donc
il paye ce sinisme il paye cette
arrogance maintenant je me Satis
absolument pas de cette situation si ce
n'est que peut-être elle va
déclencher bah un nouveau un nouvel acte
de ce quinquena par une dissolution ou
que sais-je encore mais je je pense
que on utilise un peu trop souvent ce
terme mais c'est clair qu'il y a il
s'est passé quelque chose hier dans ce
kquena et et sans doute l'incertitude
finira par aboutir sur je le disais sur
une dissolution soit un changement de
cap politique ce que je ne crois pas
mais ou des coalitions on a bien vu que
les coalitions aujourd'hui ne marchaient
pas sur les textes Emmanuel Macron il a
eu raison de refuser la démission de
geréral armanin hier ah bah il aurait
ajouté encore plus de de enfin pas le
terme de chaos mais en tout cas de de de
crise évidemment donc d'une certaine
manière oui maintenant la balle est dans
son camp c'estàd dire qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire c'est-à-dire est-ce que justement
on va aller à la dissolution est-ce que
on va remettre le le texte dans le
circuit institutionnel soit par la
commission mixte paritaire soit un
retour au Sénat donc ça c'est ouais
c'est ça ça on va en parler sur la la
démission de de Gérald haranin qui l'a
présenté qu'Emmanuel Macron a refusé
est-ce queil avait d'autres choix
Emmanuel Macron Géral daranin même s'il
a pas une côte très favorable parmi les
Français il reste un des poiss lourds du
gouvernement donc le départ d'un poid
lourd dans un gouvernement comme celui
de Monsieur Macron c'est sûr que c'est
pas un avantage pour Emmanuel Macron
donc je pense qu'il avait tout intérêt à
le garder parmi lui et par ailleurs se
poserait la question de qui à la place
de Géral Harin et on sait très bien
qu'Emmanuel Macron est le pire des DRH
de ce pays parce que souvenez-vous à
chacun des romaniments on attend jusqu'à
je sais pas combien de temps parfois
pour connaître quels seront les
successeurs d'ailleurs ça s'était posé
pour la suite de Monsieur Colomb au
ministère de l'intérieur on a attendu
attendu attendu savoir qui allait
prendre les places les plus précis jeux
parce que Monsieur Emmanuel Macron a
toujours du mal à à aller retrouver à
trouver les bonnes personne au bon
endroit donc c'est aussi ça qui se
posose pour Emmanuel Macron c'est par
qui remplacer monsieur Darmanin et puis
monsieur Darmanin tout seul à
l'extérieur c'est une personne en je le
disais il beaucoup l'enterre déjà
aujourd'hui je crois que Monsieur
Darmanin au contraire ou c'est plus
dangereux politiquement de de de le
sortir que de le garder àintérieur du
gouverement probement ou mais la
question démocratique se pose je pense
mais elle se pose c'est vrai que vous
avez raison on peut pas c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas très glorieux de voir des
députés enthousiasmé d'une défaite comme
celle-là hier mais il a notamment à
gauche la la gauche rappelle quand même
qu'on est dans une crise
institutionnelle presque de régime parce
que on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on peut
pas gouverner vous disiez c'est c'est
une erreur ou c'est une bêtise la bêtise
c'est considéré que le débat
parlementaire il se réduit à des 493 en
permanence ça fait une vingtaine de 20
493 c'est un problème quand même
démocratique important c'est tant que ça
une victoire de la gauche qui s'est
passé hier parce que maintenant le seul
texte qui reste c'est le texte du Sénat
qui est beaucoup plus dur que le texte
qui était sorti de la commission des
lois de l'assemblé c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous dis que personne ne
ressort gagnant hier et je pense pas que
la gauche soit prête à une dissolution
non plus demain s'il av une dissolution
j'ose imaginer les discussions entre
Jean-Luc Mélenchon les amis de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon les les socialistes les
écologistes et les communistes qui
s'engueulent en permanence et qui demain
repartirait en campagne sous une forme
de nupess amélioré je n'y crois pas du
tout Jean-Luc Mélenchon pourrait avoir
envie de reprendre sa revanche et dire
nous nous partons tout seul en campagne
contre tout le monde et donc du coup pas
d'accord et donc des bah des
compétitions dans les circonceptions
personne n'est prêt à une dissolution je
crois donc la gauche encore moin donc je
crois que la gauche doit prendre
conscience aussi que ce ce qui s'est
passé hier c'est le succès de l'extrême
droite aussi c'estàd c'est une volonté
de durcir les conditions d'accueil des
étrangers voire d'expulser maximement
les étrangers donc c'est quand même pas
la ligne de la gauche qui est
privilégiée aujourd'hui au sein de
l'hémicycle et dans ce qui s'est passé
hier donc je pense que la gauche ferait
mieux de se mettre au travail de la
bataille culturelle de la bataille des
idées sur la question migratoire
d'arrêter de parler du problème
migratoire d'arrêter de dire qu'il y a
une submersion migratoire dire que on a
les capacités d'accueillir mais encore
faut-il montrer comment on accueill
aujourd'hui en France c'est ça que doit
faire la gauche c'est pas que des jeux
institutionnels même s'ils sont
importants et ils sont d'une certaine
manière parce que ils ont gagné quand
même un combat contre le cynisme ce que
j'appelle le cynisme et l'arrogance de
Monsieur derman ouais c'est pas
forcément une victoire pour la gauche
jérô bah c'est une victoire pour
personne parce que le problème c'est
quand on regarde un petit peu avec
distance c'est que c'est une réforme qui
est nécessaire qui est voulu par les
Français vraiment une grande majorité et
là on voit par le spectacle qui est
donné ce sont des des des des des petits
calculs politique du cynisme de part et
d'autre qui font chuter ce la politique
aïie a dit hier gerérald oui mais c'est
il a raison d'une certaine manière
c'est-à-dire que même si lui en fait
aussi faut pas non plus voilà mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que il y a quand
même une coalition LFI RN avec le
soutien de LR et sur un une un texte
enfin unet une motion présentée par les
écologistes ça fait quand même très
désordre dans le dans le dans le jeu
politique et jeu démocratique donc
vraiment je trouve que la le le le
l'atmosphère n'est pas du tout à la
réjouissance he c'est-à-dire que alors
évidemment il y aura toujours jours des
des des des personnes qui se réjouiront
par cynisme voilà qui regarderont les
uns les autres qui a voté qui a pas voté
mais le problème le problème majeur
c'est un problème de représentation et
de représentation politique au sein du
débat public et au sein du du devant les
Français quoi c'est ça le problème parmi
qui ont voté il y a 40 députés les
républicains hier soir invité du 20hur
de TF1 Gérald armanin a fustigé leur
attitude je constate que la motion de
Roger et cette alliance des contraires
qui a choisi la la politique
politicienne qui a pas choisi l'intérêt
général et de voir deslr faire la
béquille du rassemblement national et de
la réjouissance de Madame Le Pen ça me
fait mal ça fait mal à tous les
électeurs de droite et du centre je
pense qu'on peut constater qu'après les
retraites où il y a eu une comédie où on
a vu que les n'ont pas pris leur
responsabilité pour protéger les
Français économiquement après
l'immigration les LR ne prennent pas
leur responsabilité alors que la main
était tendue c'était très clair on était
prêt au compromis on l'a dit on l'a
redit avec l'ensemble des forces
politique on voit bien que là
manifestement les LR n'ont pas envie il
font la politique du pire je regrette
perd du gros hier lesalr pour vous
pierrejacquem est-ce qu'ils ont fait la
politique du pierre comme l'a dit Gérald
haranin le problème c'est que quand on
parle des LR on sait pas de quel de quel
LR on parle vous êtes bien placé au
Sénat pour savoir que les LR du Sénat
sont pas les LR de l'Assemblée nationale
et y compris au sein même des l'IR de
l'Assemblée nationale on voit bien qu'il
y a des désaccords assez assez
importants ils ont tous un peu les
pétoches pour le dire un peu comme ça
depuis un moment quand même sur sil
devait y avoir une une dissolution dont
on parle depuis tout à l'heure quel
serait l'état des forces des
républicains parce qu'on sait plus très
bien où ils habitent à force de courir
sur l'extrême droite ils se confondent
avec Marine Le Pen et toujours vaut
mieux la l'original à la copie et
aujourd'hui et comme hier des textes qui
étaient leur essence leur philosophie
même la structure intellectuelle colonne
vertébrale politique DLR que ce soit la
réforme des retraites qui était présenté
par le gouvernement ou le projet de loi
aujourd'hui asile et immigration est
totalement compatible avec la la les les
républicains donc c'est incompréhensible
cette stratégie des républicains alors
ça évidemment ça ça ça ça participe de
la grande confusion à laquel on est en
train d'assister mais c'est vrai que le
comportement deslir est complètement
incompréhensible et euh je vois bien
qu'aujourd'hui ils vont reprendre la
main peut-être sans doute même au Sénat
je je je je j'ai toujours dit de toute
façon ici sur ce plateau avec vous Orian
que les LR était Macron compatible que
c'était un jeu de DUP auquel on
assistait que c'était une grande
hypocrisie de la part des républicains
que de pas vouloir accompagner la la la
la la le Ginat d'Emmanuel Macron il ils
ont quelque chose de commun ensemble euh
euh bon bah écoutez c'est c'est ils
seront ils seront sans doute sanctionnés
dans les urnnes jéromi ils ont perdu
gros hier pour vous les républiquain
Géral ramanan dit qu'ils ont été la
béquille du RN non mais ça c'est de la
c'est de la polémique politicienne
évidemment si one du côté de LR il y a
une justification aussi des tricotage du
texte le fait que ils ont quand même été
méprisés un peu par ce par ce pouvoir
pas d'accord de gouvernement c'està-dire
le le problème avec un groupe divisé
hein sur les 62 députés il y en a 22 qui
n'ont pas voté cette motion de rejet oui
ouais mais le j'ai j'ai fait une
interview de Daniel cbendit vous savez
qui est toujours intéressant quand même
dans le dans dans ce qu'il observe de la
vie politique donc hier qu'on peut
retrouver sur lep.fr pardon de cette
publicité mais où il dit le problème de
Emmanuel Macron c'est que il louche tout
le temps vers la vers la droite il l
vers la droite mais il va pas au bout
c'est-à-dire qu'il fait pas d'accord
c'est-à-dire que il est là et c'est
c'est le louvoimement là le problème
c'est qu'Emmanuel Macron paye un peu ses
louvoimement c'est-à-dire sur sur tous
les sujets et que que et c'est ce que
dit con Bendit d'ailleurs dans
l'interview qui a été le premier soutien
un des premiers soutiens de d'Emmanuel
Macron avant avant 2017 et qui dit que
il il a il a de bonnes idées mais il
hésite tout le temps et il n'arrive pas
donc à passer et donc là on se retrouve
évidemment dans une dans une crise
politique institutionnelle on peut pas
voir toujours la vista en politique
c'est ça le problème ouais et on a hier
des LR et duen qui ont voté la motion de
rejet parce qu'il trouvait pas le texte
assez dur la gauche qui a voté la motion
de rejet parce qu'il trouvait le texte
ex TR dur est-ce que ce qui s'est passé
hier c'est le revers du en même temps
Pierre bah oui i surtout j'entends
beaucoup de d'hommes femmes politique
commentateur a expliqué que que c'est
bah Patrick canner ce matin qui
expliquéit que c'était l'alliance de la
carpe et du lapin on sait très bien que
à droite et à gauche de l'hémicycle il y
a des visions totalement différentes de
l'immigration bon bah là il se trouve
qu'il y a une convergence stratégique
entre les formations politiques pour
faire rejeter un texte que ni l'un ni
l'autre ne veulent bon bah ils vont pas
personne n'est comptable des votes de
personne Assemblée nationale chacun vote
ce qu'il a envie de faire j'ai entendu
Delphine bateau aussi ce matin
s'exprimer qui qui a refusé de donner sa
voix à la à la à la motion de rejet en
expliquant que jamais elle justifierait
de mettre sa voix à côté de celle des de
l'extrême droite sur un texte aussi
important que celle de l'avenir des des
personnes exilées et cetera j'entends
c'est un argument qui qui se défend euh
le reste que de toute façon si ce texte
n'avait pas été adopté le texte aurait
été sans doute redurci reconsidéré à au
Sénat donc euh moi ce que je moi ce que
j'entends dans ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'on voit bien qu'il y a deux visions
aujourd'hui de la question migratoire
qui s'impose sur les bands de
l'hémicycle et que la gauche n'est pas
très audible sur la question migratoire
et qu'elle ferait mieux ce que je disais
tout à l'heure de durcir son pas d'
durcir enfin d'éclaircir son son
discours et de de proposer une autre un
autre son cloche sur la question
migratoire moi je pense qu'il y a pas
deux visions he qui qui s'affrontent il
y a plusieurs visions et c'est
d'ailleurs un des problèmes c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a aussi une gauche réaliste il y
a une gauche voilà qui est pour
l'accueil de de tout le monde il y a une
gauche réaliste de gouvernement qui est
beaucoup plus pour enfin qui est incarné
par des gens comme Manuel Vals Gérard
colon mais je connais pas de gens de
gauche à l'Assemblée nationale qui sont
pour un accueil de tout le monde Je ou
enfin dans les rangs LFI il y a quand
même des gens qui sont quand même oui
bon on prendra la liste on verra mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que il y a il y a
quand même une vision assez de de
mosaïque et d'ailleurs c'est normal
puisque c'est un problème et d'ailleurs
dans l'opinion c'est comme ça aussi
c'est-à-dire tout le monde ne pas pas
avoir une vision noir ou blanc de de de
de de ce problèmelà et donc et le
problème c'est que là qu'est-ce qui est
renvoyé dans l'opinion c'est que comme
image c'est que voilà des gens qui
refusent de débattre de de de du du du
du texte avec des sujets qui sont très
très important dans l'hémicycle et qui
d'emblé refuse de débattre donc c'est un
peu ça ça paraît abrant pour euh une
bonne partie de l'opinion et Alex la
question qui se pose maintenant c'est
après ce rejet que va devenir ce texte
qu'est-ce qui va se passer pour pour ce
projet de loi et bien comme hier soir
géralde Darmanin a balayé l'hypothèse
d'un retrait pur et simple de ce projet
de loi immigration ce que ne souhaitait
pas d'ailleurs les députés de la
majorité présidentielle et bien
maintenant il reste deux scénarios
possibles premier scénario le texte
repart directement au Sénat pour une
seconde lecture on le rappelle les
sénateurs ont déjà examiné ce projet de
loi immigration et la majorité de droite
la durcit on va en parler dans un
instant de ces durcissements second
scénario possible le gouvernement
convoque une commission mixte parétaire
SEP députés et SEP sénateurs qui doivent
se mettre d'accord sur une version
commune du texte dans cette commission
mixte parétaire et bien les cinq
parlementaires de la majorité
présidentielle vont devoir se mettre
d'accord avec les cinq parlementaires
des républicains et des centristes qui
souhaitent durcir ce projet de loi
immigration et justement queemande les
dans ce projet de loi et bien c'est
simple il suffit de regarder euh le
projet de loi qui avait été modifié par
la majorité de droite et du centre du
Sénat en novembre sur euh la mesure
phare les régularisations des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension et bien ce texte issu
du Sénat euh prévoyait que ces
régularisations devaient se faire
uniquement au cas par cas selon le
pouvoir discrétionnaire du préfet et
après un contrôle de critères très
strict et puis les républicains veulent
aussi que des quotas d'immigration
soient fixés chaque année par le
Parlement ils souhaitent durcir les
conditions du regroupement familial et
que l'aide médicale d'État qui permet de
soigner les étrangers en situation
irrégulière soit transformé en aide
médicale d'urgence avec un panier de
soins restreint et cette dernière mesure
et bien c'est une ligne rouge
inacceptable pour la majorité
présidentielle donc on le rappelle
Emmanuel Macron a chargé hier soir Géral
haranin et isabeth born de trouver une
voix de passage sur ce texte pour
essayer d'accorder majorité et les
républicains est-ce qu'il intérêt à
repartir au combat parlementaire tout de
suite Gérald hermanant sur ce texte moi
je pense pas je pense que le texte
devrait être retiré je pense que il y a
besoin d'un texte il y a besoin d'un
débat sur la question migratoire mais il
y a besoin de repenser les termes qui
sont utilisés voyez bien que l'angle
d'attaque d'un projet de loi comme
celui-là comme tous les projets de loi
sur lesqu question d'asile et
d'immigration c'est toujours pour
associer la question de l'étranger à
l'insécurité à au danger comme si le
danger ne venait que de l'extérieur de
nos frontières et c'est cette c'est
cette entrée en matière qui va pas en
fait on peut on peut proposer au débat
parlementaire une autre voix un autre
discours sur la question migratoire et
c'est c'est en ça que peut-être je peux
me réjouir que le texte a été repoussé à
l'Assemblée nationale parce qu'on aurait
entendu l'extrême droite on aurait
entendu une partie du gouvernement une
partie de la droite
avoir ce type de discours très
stigmatisant sur les sur les étrangers
et alors certes il faut être ferme sur
des sur des faits de de de délinquence
sur des faits de violence de projets
d'actes terroristme mais même moi quand
je dis ça c'est-à-dire que je vais de
l'immigration directement au projet
terroriste donc le pour moi la question
migratoire se pose en d'autres termes
vous dites qu'une partie de la gauche
proposerait que tout tout le monde soit
accueilli oui je pense qu'on a les
conditions on a les moyens d'accueillir
aujourd'hui les personnes pas nombreuses
franchement pas nombreuses qui demandent
l'asile dans notre territoire encore
faut-il que la puissance publique les
pouvoir pouvoir public les politiques
publiques mettent de l'argent sur la
construction d'hébergement proposeent
aux étrangers qui arrivent sur no
territoire de travailler de N pas
d'attendre 6 mois et d'être pris par des
entreprises qui font du travail au black
des des travailleurs sans papier a il y
a tout ça à mettre en place c'est c'est
c'est d'avantage vers ce sens là qu'il
faut qu'il faut réfléchir à un nouveau
projet de loi d'asile et d'immigration
mais certainement pas comme on le fait
depuis 10 ans une dizaine d'années où on
réduit de plus en plus ce qui est une
tradition française c'està-dire le droit
d'asile les conditions d'accueil dignes
des étrangers qui qui viennent parce que
des réglementations du des règlements du
monde guerre famine des règlements
climatiques nous sommes responsables
nous pays du Nord des mouvements de
population donc on doit y prendre plus
que notre partér oui le le texte mérite
évidemment d'être débattu dans dans
toutes ces moutures c'est-à-dire il faut
un débat de toute façon il faut une
réforme par de la version du sén du il
faut une réforme de de de de
l'immigration on a fait 30 lois depuis
1980 on a une une une un développement
une multiplication par TR des des flux
migratoires en Méditerranée 25 % de de
permis de séjour de plus quand de euh
2007 en 2017 quand enfin je veux dire il
y a une explosion donc il y a un
problème il y a un problème qui est
important euh qui est majeur et donc ce
texte moi je ne serais pas aussi euh
radical que vous c'est-à-dire que je
pense qu'il y a aussi des choses dans ce
texte ce texte a quand même été
travaillé il a été il y a y a des
moutures intéressantes il y a tout un
volet aussi sur l'intégration c'est pas
uniquement euh euh le faire de l'immigré
le Bou émissaire de de de de de la
France he enfin vous je trouve que vous
yêes des raccourcis un peu caricaturaux
mais donc vous avez entendu beaucoup
parler là dans le débat parlementaire de
la question de l'accueil de
l'apprentissage de la langue française
de la possibilité de travailler d'abord
il y a il y a pas eu de débat à
l'Assemblée donc déjà ça RAC débat
parlementaire dit parlementair ça
comprend le Sénat et puis vous avez
entendu quand même des députés réagir
sur les S qu m ça pose une question
aussi sur le le débat de la démocratie
d'opinion c'est-à-dire qu'on on ramène
souvent à des à des caricatures donc
voilà quand on regarde le texte dans son
ampleur il y a tout un volet sur
l'intégration c'est important mais ce
qui est important c'est que c'est que le
le le le débat ne soit pas justement
ravaudé et donc et donc c'est c'est ça
qui est important et d'un point de vue
ite pour répond à la question c'est que
d'un point de vue politique Gérard
armmanin évidemment
a intérêt à remettre à remettre ce ce
texte sur le sur le on suivra évidemment
ce que devient ce texte et il est à la
Une de beaucoup de vos quotidiens R ce
[Musique]
matin et Alex le rejet du projet de loi
immigration à la Une de nombreux
quotidiens régionaux et oui quasiment
toute la presse régionale titre
aujourd'hui sur le rejet du projet de
loi immigration par l'assemblée avant
même que le débat n'est commencé les
oppositions de l'anups des républicains
et du rassemblement national l'ont
emporté à 5 voix près un camouflé pour
le journal L'Alsace une crise politique
pour la montagne le journal La Dépêche
du midi fait lui je cite l'autopsie d'un
échec l'échec du en même temps sur
l'immigration avec dans ce texte d'un
côté des régularisation et de l'autre
des expulsions renforcées cela n'a pas
satisfait une majorité de députés et
puis c'est surtout l'échec du ministre
de l'Intérieur géralde Darmanin qui
était en première ligne sur ce projet
loi et d'ailleurs certains journaux
régionaux ont eu la même idée de titre
pour qualifier ce désaveux pour géralde
Darmanin la gifle à la Une de sud-ouest
de la Provence et de Nice Matin la
claque pour le journal Le Dauphiné
Libéré Gérald Darmanin ne s'attendait
peut-être pas à essuyer ce rejet avant
même que le débat ne se tienne à
l'Assemblée logiquement après ce revers
il a présenté sa démission à Emmanuel
Macron qui a refusé en le chargeant de
se remettre au travail pour trouver une
voie de passage sur ce texte le ministre
de l'Intérieur va peut-être donner
encore des gages aux républicains pour
durcir ce projet de loi tout en essayant
de garder unie la majorité
présidentielle et Alex on parle
également de l'uniforme ça y est va être
expérimenté avec cole et oui Gabriel
Atal le ministre de l'éducation
nationale l'avait laissé entendre en
septembre et c'est désormais certain il
y aura bien une expérimentation de
l'uniforme à l'école dans certains
territoires cela fait la une du
populaire du centre et de l'union de
reins à reins notamment 1200 élèves vont
porter l'uniforme en 2024 et on sait
déjà ce que ce que vont recevoir les
familles CIN polos deux pulls et deux
pantalons pour un cout de 200 € financé
à par régal par l'État et la
collectivité la facture va d'ailleurs
s'élever à 100000 € pour la ville de
reins alors le ministre de l'Éducation
Gabriel Attal n'est pas encore convaincu
par l'intérêt de l'uniforme à l'école il
est conscient qu'il y a beaucoup de
dogmatisme autour de ce sujet mais il
attend de voir si cela peut un peu
apaiser le climat scolaire à Deville une
vente aux enchères historiques d'un
cheval de course et oui c'est à la Une
du journal du pays d'uge une jument de 4
ans a fait exploser les enchères àville
ce weekend avec une enchère qui est
montée jusqu'à 4 millions d'euros
déboursé par un acheteur en ligne c'est
un prix record la police chapelle place
du du carousel elle a été élevée dans un
aras de Clarbec dans le Calvados et elle
appartenait aux écuries du Qatar et
forcément bien le directeur de Sara
avait un sentiment mitigé au moment de
la vente nous sommes à la fois contents
et très tristes car c'était une pouliche
exceptionnelle qui nous a fait vivre des
émotion hors du commun en remportant de
nombreuses courses merci Alex pour cette
histoire en garde vos unes la Une de
Politi cette semaine extrême droite la
contagion mondiale et cette question la
France basculera-t-elle oui ça c'est le
numéro de cette semaine qui est en train
de de se terminer et là je file à la
rédaction pour boucl le numéro qu'on
vous prépare sur cette jeunesse qui
agite qui affolle qui excite les RAC ce
sera à suivre la semaine prochaine le
point pareil la semaine qui se termine
après les banlieux les centrevillees la
loi des dealers pour la semaine qui
arrive Jérôme pour le le numéro on est
en train de le faire donc je peux vous
dire il y a plus de supense du côté du
point on regarde votre livre Jérôme
après la nuit c'est aux éditions Kalman
Levi merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été
avec nous merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi à 18h vous avez rendez-vous avec
Thomas HUG pour sens public très bonne
journée à
demain